you want to um talk about some of the
advice you have here in these points
about vetting for a spouse
about what I'm sorry about vetting for a
spouse you got some really good talking
points here on this email that you sent
me about vetting for a spouse and red
flags attachment Styles I think it's a
ton of value in you going through this
first so yeah maybe take like 15 20
minutes and and hit on those and then
we'll take the call in yeah for sure
uh I appreciate the opportunity to talk
about through my lunch as a divorce
lawyer in over 90 percent of divorce
nasty divorce cases uh one of two things
are present somebody has a personality
disorder okay narcissistic personality
disorder borderline personality disorder
um
histrionic you know or they have an
untreated mental health issue uh that is
one of two things the other thing is is
uh their attachment style right people's
attachment Styles and you should go down
the rabbit hole if you've never heard of
this there's four types of attachment
style there's secure attachment style
there's uh avoidant
dismissive avoiding attachment style
there is fearful attachment Style
uh you don't there's anxious attachment
style so unless you're secure or your
partner is secure you're going to be in
a world of hurt
all these attachment Styles develop from
infancy to about five years old and what
happens is somebody has
a caretaker that is not really there for
them whether they have a drug problem or
alcohol problem or they're just not
present and the child never really is
able to be their own person they're
always afraid they can't go too far away
because the person their caretaker isn't
doing a good job taking care of them so
they don't develop right and what
happens is in adulthood they never shake
this problem
so for example
um
if you're a div if you marry a
dismissive avoidant person
they're going to Stonewall you
uh you're gonna walk into a room and
you're going to get a cold shoulder and
they're going to say
I'm fine everything's okay
just what do you why do you think that
something's wrong and they're they're
going to pull away emotionally and
physically
don't marry them because you are going
to be in constant
up and down and through no fault of your
own you're going to be on eggshells
so if you're dating someone that pulls
away a lot or they're not all in and you
feel that you haven't done anything
wrong but they have these feelings and
fears that get in the way of having a
truly great connection
go down the rabbit hole the chances are
this all started in their childhood uh
anxious attachment style this person is
preoccupied with problems and issues
that don't really exist they also pull
away but they come back so it's like
this push-pull cycle it will drive you
nuts and if you marry them
you know how can you really be happy
living under the same roof you never
know what you're going to be walking
into they're anxious because their
caregiver did not focus in on their
needs as they were developing there's a
whole school of psychology on this and
if you don't know about it you don't
know what to look for you just think oh
all women are like that or all people
are like that no they're not no they're
not and
it's only going to be a matter of time
if you don't vet carefully to have a
situation where you can't take it
anymore I mean
life is short and if you are constantly
having a second guess what it is you're
doing wrong with the person that you're
married to
you're going to drive yourself crazy
um so and I don't want that I want to
keep you out of my office and I want you
to go live your best life
are these attachment cells something
that you've seen pop up over and over
again in your practice uh dismissive
avoiding anxious attachment fearful yeah
you know I'll listen to Somebody's story
and it could be a man or a woman uh and
when I get into the nitty-gritty of
what's really going on I always ask
divorce clients is there any way this
marriage can be saved because that would
be especially if they have kids right
most good divorce lawyers are going to
ask that question right if if it's just
something stupid that they're fighting
over yeah ask them to get counseling
especially if there are kids like we're
not looking to get you divorced but
yes and once I learned about these
attachment Styles the healthy ones
secure and the unhealthy ones
um it comes up on repeat all the time so
you know sometimes people's fears
outweigh their feelings and they get
in a place where they just need to
detach
the problem is when they detach for
all the time like a constant I'm okay I
have to detach I'm okay I have to detach
that's a problem that I see in high
conflict divorces and all of these
problems started from infancy to five
years old when they were trying to bond
with their caretaker if you look at
little kids you know they'll go away
from their mom or dad but they'll always
look back look back uh and if the
caretaker is there they get that
confidence that they can conquer the
world I always like I always say like
nothing's more powerful than a
five-year-old in a Superman costume you
know they can like do anything but if
their parent isn't consistent and
they're not there
they bring that to adulthood and they
don't let the relationship Bloom and
flourish and then eventually the other
partner if they have that too it's a
recipe for disaster if the other partner
is secure they can be patient but it's
not the best life that they're living
and eventually they say this is crazy a
lot of times the person will withdraw
emotionally and intimately so
any sort of intimacy is inconsistent at
best because the other person's
preoccupied with things that
they shouldn't be preoccupied with but
they can't help it so not to plain blame
on people it's just the attachment style
is a huge issue and something you should
vet for so you're looking for
narcissistic personality disorder
histrionic uh someone that can take
responsibility for their own uh station
in life that's one or untreated mental
health issues somebody that is very
seriously depressed and will not seek
treatment there's no shame in that I
mean there's modalities to help that and
then the attachment style if you see
someone drifting away and you know the
overarching thing is you have to be able
to trust the other person too without
trust there's really nothing there to
build on so
trust is a given without that there's no
discussion really you're not going to
marry someone you don't trust but these
attachment styles are prevalent and if
you're aware of them you could go down
the rabbit hole there's a ton of
information about it I think was started
by a psychologist in the 1950s and it
rings true in divorce court I see it all
the time where that if you have two
people who are uh have bad attachment
Styles both dismissive you're not
getting anywhere uh it will never if you
have kids with them if you have kids
with each other the kids are going to be
in the middle of that it's not healthy
it's better to stay single work on your
issues recognize it and then you know
get into a relationship if that's what
you really want so
um
that that's kind of it on my attachment
style sermon I uh yeah another really
good points and I haven't I haven't
talked about attachment sales before and
I've come across this stuff
at least a few times in the past year
and but I've looked at it it looks
interesting but it's like
you know I get to the point where it's
like okay you know I've identified the
red flags that you know that popped up
over and over again during consults
during Collins you know made a bunch of
notes that's you know it's pretty clear
that you know you're going to invite a
degree of Chaos in your life and I'm
sure that the attachment styles are
correlated to some degree with the red
flags or the dangerous personality types
like psychopathy or narcissism or are
intermingled in there so it's like you
really have your work cut out for you
when it comes to
letting a partner for marriage and
understanding The Slaughterhouse of
family law that you generally walk into
I mean it's better it's it's better in
some places it's not so much you know I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out